[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURA LING: You're
a philosopher.
You've been described
as a Timothy
Leary for the viral video age.
What sorts of things are you
waxing poetic about these days?
JASON SILVA: Pretty
much every time
I stumble upon an idea that
captures my imagination,
something articulated in
a counter intuitive way,
a different spin on
technology, a different spin
on the future of humanity, that
kind of gets my motors going
really, really fast.
LAURA LING: Tell me about
your series "Shots of Awe."
JASON SILVA: So "Shots of
Awe" came from a desire
to use media, to use cameras
to immortalize inspiration.
I refuse to accept
that these moments had
to be passing moments.
I was like no, no, no.
I choose to film them, to
record them, to capture them.
And it was a way of gaining
control over these experiences.
And I could create an
intersubjective communication
with somebody else,
because I actually
got to show you what it
was like to be in my head
when I had this epiphany.
So "Shots of Awe" are
philosophical espresso shots,
this condensed
trailers for ideas.
What they hint at
is the exception,
a vision of something more.
LAURA LING: Tell me
about your process,
your ritual, how you
are able to come up
with these stream of
consciousness riffs?
JASON SILVA: I started getting
into this idea of flow states
because I read this
article that talked
about doing brain scans
on freestyle rappers
when they were improvising.
And then they did
brain scans on them
when they were reciting
memorized lyrics.
And what the studies
found, a part
of the brain that is responsible
for our self-editing, our sense
of self-consciousness, that part
goes dim during the freestyle.
So essentially, you're
getting out of your own way.
It's like that line
in "Black Swan" that
say perfection is not
just about control,
it's also about letting go.
So I can have all my
notes and my thoughts
and my ideas and this and that.
But then I go for the walk.
I go into the woods.
I go to Sea Ranch, California.
I go to Big Sur.
I go to some park.
And just the stroll and the
disconnection from distraction
gets your brain daydreaming.
When you're in
daydreaming mode, you
start to do a little bit
of the lateral thinking.
So you start connecting
this to that and this.
So you start to go
through the aha moments.
And if you are lucky enough
to have the camera around,
you're capturing
that real time flow.
It's creativity
happening in real time.
I mean it literally
feels like channeling.
So for me, I figured out
how to create my flow state.
And the results tend to be these
riffs that people really love.
And they're like what,
there's no script.
That was a completely
extemporaneous stream
of consciousness?
I'm normally kind of an
introvert and kind of shy
in most social situation.
But if the conditions are
right, like a flame it emerges.
We never have a true,
accurate rendition of reality
because it's all about our
perception, our projections,
our longings.
Our romantic partners
are creations
and we are the creators.
LAURA LING: So you said if you
can create that flow state,
how do create it?
JASON SILVA: I have found
that the best way is to take
yourself out of context,
so a new experience,
a new space in a new place so
that I transcend what Michael
Pollan calls the been there's
and done that's of the adult
mind/ And I can enter the
consciousness of the child.
I can be in wonderment.
I can be curious
about everything
around me-- so rest,
relaxation, novel spaces, novel
environments,
disconnection, disconnection
from the every
day, disconnection
from your daily
responsibilities,
disconnection from
your trivialities,
just a daydream space,
a space to dream,
to fuse cognition and dream.
LAURA LING: What happens when
you don't achieve that flow?
JASON SILVA: If
it's not working,
I become highly anxious.
Actually, irritable is
probably the best word.
I just kind of retreat.
I just withdraw.
LAURA LING: Can you describe how
it feels to be in that state?
JASON SILVA: It feels like
unbelievable lucidity, instant
recall, just this capacity to
explain what you're feeling
and what you were
thinking effortlessly.
Do we love the harder?
Do we squeeze tighter?
You just feel your best,
and you perform your best.
The minute you choose one
thing you've effectively
said no to everything else.
And there's a gnawing anxiety in
realize that you can't possibly
have it all.
I'm like a reality hacker.
I'm like literally hacking
my ontological reality.
And I'm studying how to trigger
certain moods and modalities.
I'm literally playing
with my consciousness
so that I can feel how I want
to feel when I want to feel it
as often as possible.
LAURA LING: How
important is this ritual
of achieving that flow state?
JASON SILVA: Hugely important.
You are building the
foundations for something
magical to happen.
The ritual is as important
as chopping the wood
and making sure it's dry
before you light the fire.
It's providing the
necessary ingredients
for you cognitive salad.
It's very, very,
very, very important.
Almost, I would say
that it's everything.
LAURA LING: I hope
you were inspired
by Jason Silva's ritual and
discover your own flow state.
This series is so
special to me because I
learn something new from
every person we future.
We have so many more intriguing
episodes of rituals coming up,
so please, please subscribe to
watch them and so much more.
And be sure to check out
this other episode of rituals
to see how this Hollywood
stuntman prepares
to get lit on fire.
JAMES ARMSTRONG: If I'm
about to do something
and I feel my heart
thumping or my hand shaking,
then I'll close my
eyes and I breathe,
[INHALING]
JAMES ARMSTRONG: There
is no other distraction,
no other thought.
It's just this absolute pinpoint
focus of the task at hand.